[Music]
all right let's go out to Tampa Florida
and talk to Ann hey an what's
up can you hear me I hi Dr John I can
hear you what's
up not too much how are you good good
good good what's up in your
world okay so my question is um how do I
support my husband while he Grieves
losing his job and navigating
constant rejection while finding a new
one but still holding him accountable to
getting a job and not making excuses for
all the reasons why he can't do certain
things o that one's that's tough um
let's start at the back end of the
question and work the other way um okay
for you to say the words I need to hold
him
accountable tell me about that I think I
know where you're going but I want to
hear you say it well
it just seems like he's trying to find
work I know he's trying but he's maybe
not trying as hard as I think he could
or maybe in the ways I think he should
be
um and it's always kind of like well you
know I'm not going to apply for that one
because well the hours are not great or
it doesn't work
or the pay isn't enough you know it's
always just kind of something or I I had
wine it was like well they want me to do
this project and I'm not going to do
this project before I have a job you
know it's kind of like
excuses and it Narrows his his his you
know applications and and so I'm kind of
like well you know what you're doing
isn't working so let's try something
else but I also know he's he's really
struggling right it it's it's hard it's
been hard for him and the more rejection
right the harder it is so I'm kind of
trying to navigate you
know pushing him but understanding that
it's hard oh man um I've got some
probably controversial thoughts on this
topic but I'm just going to speak
directly I don't have a lot of
literature on this I'm gonna speak
directly from my guts okay okay um first
off while you're talking it reminded me
of uh there's that scene in Dumb and
Dumber when it's like there's no jobs
out there and I think it's Lloyd
Christmas goes yeah unless you want to
work 40 hours a
week all right so
exactly um do you have kids by the way
yes we have two kids in daycare so we
both work full-time so the kids are
still in daycare so is he is he have
some sort of just Band-Aid job right now
or is he just sitting at home applying
just sitting at home applying he's he's
tried to sign up for like instacart and
Uber and all of that and they're all all
the weight lists are full um he did do
like one cat sitting right um okay so
here okay I I wish he was on the phone
he's not so you're going to feel some of
the smoke from me and it's not aimed at
you okay it's aimed at men in America
how about that um I remember as a young
kid I was at a church um that was I'd
say somewhat of an affluent Church
before affluent churches were were a
thing um in my neighborhood growing up
it it's a neighborhood church but it was
pretty big and people did pretty well
and I remember there was a
man who got fired from his executive
job and he asked for a meeting with the
Elders of the church on Sunday
afternoon and by Monday they had fired
their custodial staff and this former
executive was cleaning the toilets at
the church and emptying waste
baskets and I remember a couple years
later I got out of college and I was a
high school teacher and we had this uh I
was driving through town and as I was
pulling into get sign my R paperwork of
this I was going to be a teacher now a
high school teacher I actually saw him
driving out and I saw a sign in the yard
and it was like a open day basically it
was like a job
fair and I remember
thinking
this is what masculinity looks like this
man will do anything to pay the life
bill and the water bill and put food on
his
table and it was the most like I'm so
glad I got to see that both up close
like just my dad worked at the church
after we quit being a police officer and
I saw I'd be up there just messing
around in his office and I'd see this
guy walking through in jeans in a dress
shirt cleaning toilets empty in trash
and I know he was applying like crazy
but the job market was a mess especially
for executives and his thing he did and
then he went and got a job as a
teacher
right he went and got a job and I was
driving in rural Tennessee the other day
taking my daughter to breakfast and I
saw a sign the McDonald's was $20 an
hour MH 20 bucks an
hour um almost every store down the way
had jobs
open and now since applications all even
give people a pass in old days that you
had to wait right you had to try to
catch somebody during the
day now I can work two full-time fast
food jobs and making $20 an hour and
maybe not where you live so maybe $15 an
hour although I bet it's more in Tampa
you can work and then all night after
the kids are in bed you can apply for
jobs apply for jobs apply for
jobs and I'm going to say something
that's unpopular because I talk about
grief all the time he doesn't have time
for that in this
moment I remember one of my close
friends um her husband was just a dead
beat packed up and left her pregnant
with child number
three and I remember asking her how are
you doing this and she said I don't know
but I don't have that option to
not right yep we will figure this out I
have two children staring at me saying
mommy I'm hungry and I have a third one
about to be
born so there was a season a time for
grief it wasn't when that that dead beat
packed up and took
off because those babies had to
eat so I think right now the
conversation has to shift from you get a
season of mourning and let's be sad
about the loss of a job dude the data is
clear a job loss especially for somebody
who has identified a career as an
identity like I'm a dentist I am an
attorney I'm a executive whatever is
similar to um losing a loved one it's
really it's it's hard on your body it's
hard on your mind it's hard on your
identity it's hard on everything and
then you got to go get a a freaking job
because our family needs
money right and so I have
zero zero compassion in this
moment none zero okay you go find
work and I know that's easy for me to
say that's really difficult for you
isn't
it because you're in the house with him
right right and you have to navigate the
mood swings and the oh my gosh and this
is just not going to be a good fit for
us and what right and by the way you're
getting up and going to work every day
right right and this is when the
resentment starts to slowly creep in
right and then intimacy becomes hard
because respect is hard and competency
see competency is hard like all of it
just works together right right
y so what have you tried so far that has
not worked or did some big thing happen
and that's why you called or is this
just this dripping ongoing no it's it's
just been ongoing yeah it's just been
how long and I told him it has been
seven
months and I told him at the time he got
Severance right so we had a couple
months and we we you know we're debt
free we have our we have a ton of money
and savings so we're fine but I told
them I said there's going to come a
point where you get any job or the kids
are going to stay home and you're you're
now full-time dad right because of the
cost of daycare absolutely um and he he
says he understands and all that and I
know he's you know he's trying he's at
that point where he's trying to get
those like gig jobs right
but but it's the it's just kind of I
feel like excuses right or on a waight
list list one million percent 1 million
per. right throw the gig jobs out the
window you know why he wants a gig job
because he can
hide right go put on a visor and serve
Burger
King yeah it's a noble job you're
helping people
eat and more than that it's a noble job
because you're showing your kids what it
looks like to get hit in the mouth and
get back up
right and so if I'm you I would have a
conversation it'd be a hard one but
again not in not at
home but sitting down and saying okay
this going to be a hard conversation and
you're going to want to duck out I need
you to stay with me will you stay with
me and he'll say yes I love you I want
to be married to you here's where we are
7 months have gone by what you're doing
is not
working I need the man I married to have
a job at the local McDonald's at Walmart
shipping boxes at night I don't care
what it is but I need you to get up
every day with a purpose MH or
transition fully if y'all can afford it
to you are now stay-at-home Dad we stop
daycare January 1 one mhm and that's
it because you have shown over the last
seven
months that you're really not interested
in getting a job he's probably waiting
for somebody to call him and say hey I
got a six figure met it's not gonna that
Call's not coming Call's not
coming and here's the weird thing I
don't know how it works or why it works
but he's if he is a sixf figure kind of
guy he'll start working at McDonald's
and he'll own three of them in the next
months I don't know how that works they
just
do he'll start working at home deepo and
become a senior manager just because he
shows up and doesn't quit on people
right and and that's why part of the
reason I get so frustrated is because
he's so smart and he could do anything
it's just getting him to do
it yeah so when Dr Henry Cloud talks
about parents and their kids he talks
about what often people need in this
situation is they need some problems MH
like a kid if this was your 25y old kid
they would need to move out or they
would need to start paying
rent and so I think there has to be some
level of hey honey you're making this
choice and so on behalf of the family
we're going to start making these I'm
gonna start making these choices I got
to protect these kids from thinking this
is what being a dad looks
like I've got to protect me because I
want to be married to you and I just am
losing respect in you because you lay on
the couch all day
is that fair are you are you there I'm
there I'm there I'm there for you I'm
there for you I just have such a clear
picture of a man that wouldn't clean
toilets in my church building and dude
I'll respect him till the end of
time right and I'm with you you know I
would I I've lost a job before right and
I went back out and got another one
immediately right and I know the job
Market's different and all that um it's
just and I I listen you took a call on
the ramsy show a couple days ago and you
called the guy out and it was like
you're just making excuses and I was
like oh man that's my husband it's like
well I can't do this and I can't you
know and I was just
like that's what it is it's all it is
have you told him honey I I don't
respect you
anymore I haven't no okay I think that
we may be at a place where honesty is
important I love
you but I've watched you become a shell
of who you were no because you've lost
purpose and if your purpose isn't
professional then my God let your
purpose be me let your purpose be our
kids let your purpose be
you but now it's become just a way of
life it's become a wallow and let's be
honest why would he get up right right
you aren't starving you still sleep with
him occasionally he don't have to mess
with his kids at all he get to play he
gets to play uh fortnite you know with
kids on the other side of the world in
the middle of night I got don't what
he's doing what does he do all day he
he's supposedly sitting at his computer
applying for job I mean he does chores
he's picked up a lot of the laundry and
he does chores you know what's so scary
about the way you said that and I knew
this was coming you are transitioning to
his
mother right because he is a child he's
a
child and everybody out there let me
just say if you have a six-figure job
and you've got this big identity and you
get fired they lay you off of course you
take a couple of weeks to recalibrate of
course what just happened I'm calling my
contacts I'm GNA have cups of coffee
with people and then go do a
thing go do a
thing go get a job are you gonna be a
career server no but go get a job begin
to give yourself something that you have
to wake up for you have to shower for
you have to greet other
people and that will help clear the
cobwebs that helps rattle you like
through your
bones get up and go get him
man and for those of you stuck with
somebody who is becoming a dead beat or
who is one or who's always scheming well
I got a plan I don't want to work at
that place because they make me work
late sometimes I don't want to work over
there because they
have have the hard conversation and tell
the
truth it's hard for me to be attracted
to somebody that won't
work I've lost respect in you for seven
months for one year for five years
you've sat here and waited for a phone
call for the quote unquote perfect
job you sit at your computer all
day and I drive by sign after sign after
sign saying Help want it help want it
help
wanted go get a
job and apply at your computer after
we're all in after the kids are in bed
after I'm in bed then spend your time
dreaming in front of the
computer go get a
job if you lose a job that's powerful
and important to you yes there's going
to be a season of grief yes no question
about it I'm not callous I'm not an
idiot I've grieved jobs that I've
left but you got to go to work you got
to go to
work I'm so sorry and thanks for the
call let me know how that conversation
goes that's a that's a nuclear option
telling your husband you don't you don't
respect
him I think that's where we
are